the attacks in France have cast a long
shadow over Parliament's first plenary
session of 2015 prompting strong
political responses and calls for new
ways to deal with radicalization the
exchange of information between security
agencies is a big part of it to em eps
have a particular expertise in this
german green young Philip al breast and
British Conservative timothy car coat
first are they Charlie and what does the
name you mean to them when the president
of the Parliament asked those members
present to go outside and stand silently
for a minute I certainly had my sign not
only was this an appalling terrorist
atrocity but also it was a terrorist
atrocity addressed directly at free
speech we are all Charlie and also our
net and we are also Jewish so we can see
we have to be together it's about a kind
of European identity where we want to be
open we want to be tolerant to different
religions to different origin small s
and we want to be safeguarding our where
use after the attacks who is now at risk
everybody is in direct risk in one way
or another that is why I think they've
been so many people reacting to what has
happened all of us are at risk if we
don't actually protect our freedom there
is a risk that such attacks will not be
at the only ones we have to be very
careful analyzing the risks and we have
to focus on them we have to follow the
people which are radicalizing themselves
or others you have to be careful not to
need jack too much and say look because
something terrible has happened like
this we now have to do a whole list of
new things the answer is of course that
we should support our our security
services we should support the rule of
law we should deal with criminals and
terrorists as appropriately as we
possibly can firmly determinately I'm
convinced that we would have
at a better situation and also a better
chance to prevent these attacks if there
would be better cooperation already in
place until now which is not the case we
don't exchange the information which we
have I would like that we focus on
strengthening the police and justice on
security officials which are locally and
regionally analyzing the situation and
bringing them together what's to happen
to the proposed system of transferring
air passenger information known as
passenger name records on all flights
crossing Europe the fact that the
circumstance has occurred which now
highlights it's possible usefulness is
important to the extent that I hope that
we might now concentrate on getting it
through this Parliament I would prefer
to look at it as a tool which is
available or should be available to deal
with criminals not just terrorists
people who are trafficking in children
pedophiles people who are using the drug
trade for instance people who are
committing serious crimes of all kinds I
cannot really understand why ministers
and some politicians in the parliament
are now calling for a system which is
retaining passenger named records of
completely innocent and not suspicious
people while we have quite a lot of
information on suspicious people on
risky regions and also risky groups of
persons and we are not focusing on them
because today's laws already allow us to
track them if there is a reason a
suspicion or risk and I think that's the
thing which what we should do instead of
putting a general suspicion towards
everybody which is just endangering the
where use which we just want to prevent
and protect how can the radicalization
of young people European citizens be
countered an awful lot of this is coming
out of our own societies in which case
one has to look back and say when does
this start to occur and what are the
circumstances I don't believe the one
political
or or initiative taken in some part of
the world which is offensive to a young
person is what causes this I think this
is from the point of view of very young
people I think there is an issue
regarding education I think there is an
issue regarding tolerance I think there
are issues here which need to be tackled
by the nation states themselves we have
to look at the issue of race relations
community relations and see whether
we're handling that right in our in our
countries and in our cities I think
there's a lot to be done not only loss
will prevent people to be radicalized we
need to focus also on the challenges in
the social environment the economic
situation of many especially young
people is so bad in Europe at the moment
especially in some member states where
there is a high youth unemployment we
need to really do much more to invest in
their future because otherwise those
people without any future will perhaps
radicalize themselves and will fight
against the system which we don't want
them to do